Sal Khan lives in California.
Sarisha Sadeed over half the world away in Dubai.
Their lives are interconnected, but Khan doesn't know.
This is the story of how one man helps education in the world
but they never see themselves with their students.
Where does your passion come from?
Well, I think I always liked to teach.
He is a man who has won a lucrative place in Silicon Valley.
It might look like a boring job.
I'm full of negative feelings now,
but when it comes to managing education, it's never about money.
Khan could make millions.
He was one of the most successful students of his college with a perfect point score in SATs (a standardized test for US universities).
Then MIT (Massachusetts Institute of Technology) came to Bill Clinton.
Then Harvard Business School, where he got to the hedge funds and it suited him.
But Khan, who had a wife and son who supported him, threw it all behind.
Many people think I'm a little crazy.
Obviously you know that if you have every waking hour to sneak into the room
and create math video and put it on Youtube.
People then come up with the question: "What is it?"
This is happening, Khan's Youtube videos.
Let's do a few more examples and I think you could get into it.
Users around the world have been clicked at least 9 million times.
Topics range from mathematics,
to chemistry and economics.
You can use these videos for each educational field. He really helps.
One of the users is nineteen-year-old Sirisha from Dubai, studying the second year of college.
She says the videos help her understand the fabric.
I spend about two days before each test
watching videos and understanding the little details they explain.
This gigantic virtual school comes from the smallest places.
From a small dressing room converted to Salo's room.
This is where it is able to reach around 80,000 users looking for education in a month.
It all started a few years ago when a cousin wanted some online math tutorial.
Quite soon, other relatives began to ask for similar help.
Suddenly, the people Sal didn't know began to watch these tutorials.
You need to teach people math terms and then find out
it's all connected.
There is still a small proportion of people going on Youtube and going googlit to find the biggest common divisor.
People did that.
Now they have Khan's school.
Videos are short and created simply using Sal's voice and elements
with a simple black background and graphics
There are many people who need help with something.
It doesn't matter if it's mathematics, other science or anything else.
And I think that the fact that they will find these videos on Youtube is ideal.
There are many people like Sarah Saldeeds.
She and her friends refer to Khan as "men with colorful thoughts".
Whatever you think of him or his teaching,
the success of his website confirmed his decision to leave hedge funds.
Dan Simon CNN San Francisco